mis d'accord hier pas
d'oseille ça été dil tout dans ma
fouille bien entendu les chéres on a une
discussion il y a un instant entre benim
et cardose et c'est vrai que on a eu une
révélation ils nous ont ils se sont
confiés à
nous sortir encore et il y a un instant
ils nous ont dit que en fait et ben
franchement cétait chaud c'est chaud les
deux genre dimanche genre diman il y en
a un des deux ah qui a Ken toute la
journée ah un des deux à vous de trouver
à vous de trouver de qui il s'agit c'est
Valérie c'est JAC par sa femme est
rentrée de de voyage donc il a rattrapé
ça il y a peut-être un piège euh ah
alors c'est Valérie un des deux ou les
deux benim est-ce que c'est toi
franchement je dis la vérité non alors
non enfin peut-être peut-être sair jacqu
est-ce que c'est toi est-ce que je dis
la vérité comme tu veux peut-être
quoi infos les infos est-ce que tu peux
nous dire qui a toute la journée
dimanche bah j'ai une question déjà pour
Jacques oui bah ton âge tuarve
encore merci allez
mercimion merci merci on Ann tout merci
on annule le prime on annule tout merci
allez tu prendsairesz TER V
allez intéressant comme question très
intéressant si tu veux je te donne le
portable de ma
femme je croyais pas que ça allait
démarré comme
ça tout à l'heure tu as quand même dit
que tu avais une préférence pour les
hommesend que entendu il a parlé des
hommes oui c'est vrai parl hommes si si
si si si si si mais ce que tu veux on te
jugera jamais non mais je te dis on ne
te jugera jamais jamais jamais jamais
jamais Daniel quand est-ce que c'est
quoi la dernière fois que tu as fait
l'amour dans les années 90 dans les
années 90 et ben on va en parler tout à
l'heéo c'est un truc de fouille est-ce
que c'est bientôt Noël
bonjour c'est bientôt Noël et oui c'est
bientôt Noël qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire vous à Noël alors tous parce que
est-ce que vous avez déjà tous acheté
des cadeaux c'est toujours une tané les
cadeaux de Noël moi je j'attends
toujours voilà que les gens me fassent
des
cadeaux d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
préférez faire des cadeaux ou recevoir
des cadeau faire des cadeau cade par que
moi je
déteste non mais franchement c'est vrai
quand vous préférez faire des cadeaux
êtes vraiment des petits
myth on adore chercher on pense à un ça
F plaisir puis cade moi je me fais un
cadeau de Noël à moi-même ah
ou ouais ça y est alors il est dans le
parking
non je rigole je rigole non non mais
mais c'est vrai que je me fais je me
fais souvent des cadeaux de Noël à
moi-même parce que personne me fait de
cadeau moi
oh C vous avez tout si vous aviez un
cadeau à me faire ce serait quoi
franchement voilà un cadeau là vous
dites voà dit qu'on allait le faire on
pense un cadeau à cy ce serait quoi vous
pensez à quoi tout de Lego vous en
manquez donc leg des
Lego
leg des LEGO avec plaisir j'adore
franchement moi des trucs par rapport à
la beauté au soins je me dis une belle
crème pour le corp une poudre du tal
comm
[Rires]
çaux j'avais les moyens vous offrir la
voiture de vos rêves
V alors c'est qu'il aime
ça reste encore de la
place
franchement toi tu m'of alors comme on a
une passion commune je vous offre un
weekend avec moi à Disneyland parce que
vous adorez Disney non mais parce j'ai
dit un cadeau pas un
cauchemar mais comme vous avez tout vous
pouvez tout vous
offrir quoi ce cadeau là non non c'est
quoi non mais t'enmeres pas t'emmerde
pas On se fait pas de cadeau cette année
on fait l'impasse on fait l'impasse fr
toi un petit un parc d'attraction privé
pour vous pour avec vos potes faire tous
vos
[Musique]
délires j'aime bien
c'est pas
mal moi un dîner 5 étoiles avec la
personne de ton
choix B m que des
conneries très bien je m que des Conner
c'est mignon quand même non non là dire
mais c'est difficile quoi c'est
difficileah de t'offrir des cadeaux je a
un qui a pas dit ma
passion les gars un beau
bouquin
philosophie je va un peu
bouiner chéri je un peu tu connais les
il a toujours des yeues un couple de
yeuv en vacances et tentend à la piscine
le gars il fait chéri je vais un peu
bouquiner dans la
chambre qu'il va regarder
pub conis les
gars vrai ou pas mais g
arrte je connais ça à la piscine frère
je connais les gars arrêtez les gars
arrêtez arrêtez vous l'avez déjà fait
mais non
c'est pas le gen de la maison tu peux y
aller je suis même pas dans pas comme
toi
Guill du tout tu sais moi je suis acteur
de ma vie je suis pas
spectateur pas al moi je vous ai déjà
fait un cadeau parce que début 2024
c'est un vrai cadeau vous devez fraer
fort niveau style frapper très fort je
vous ai acheté nouvel accessoire mode
c'est quoi des boucles d'oreilles
créoles Grande Boucle d'oreill je pense
que c'est votre nouveau truc arrête de
dire des conneries vent je mettre des
boucl d'oreill des oiseaux dessus aussi
connard est-ce que vous avez déjà vu la
nouvelle mode chez les hommes je vais
faire l'impass sur cette mode il y a des
trucs que que je peux suivre mais ça non
je te le dis ça non benim tu m'as pas
dit si si j'avais les moyens je ferais
construire ici un terrain de paddle
comme ça vouses un padle vous allez tout
suite vous raconter une Dara vous savez
qu' un moment j'étais en train de
ressigner mon contrat et j'ai dit aux
équipes j'ai dit voilà peut-être est-ce
qu'on peut pas créer un terrain de
paddle mettre voilà dans le contrat
terrain de padol ici donc je vous jure
que vrai on était avec franc cap étudi
on a étudié pour voir la hauteur tout ça
on était commeass avec les gars ouais
non si on le met là et à un moment on a
eu l'idée de le mettre à l'entrée
c'estàdire que pour rentrer dans la
canal Factory tu dois traverser genre
attends 2 minutes on finit un point 2
minutes j'ai rendez-vous bah tuattends
tu rien à 5 4 2è set non mais je
on s'est demandé et franchement ça
aurait été incroyable ça aurait été
incroable vous vous avez pensé à quelque
chose h du parfum pourquoi je plus
qu'est-ce qu' ça pluss fois qu' dis ça
ça fait plusieurs fois que vous le disz
dit même en polonaise pour dire vous dit
mais non mais c'est non mais ça il y a
un problème de non c'est un beau cadeau
oui c'est un beau cadeau non mais il y a
un problème ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'elle dit que histoire d'odeur entre
vous un problème mais c'est des cadeau
accessibles c'est plus accessible qu'une
voure dire chose derre FO la dernière
fois a dit que je a dit qu'elle m'offre
un parfum frère il y a un problème
thématique non sans déconner non mais tu
peux le dire bah non mais j'ai pas senti
ça va ça va ça
va
c'est super bon tu toi c'est bon toi
voiture is ça bon bah très bien on a
tous les cadeaux les gars pou c'est Mo
j'aimerais bien si j'avais de l'argent
te mettre avec les top 3 des plus grands
champions de paddle le top 3 met dedans
non à 4 4 1 2 3 et les TR trois plus
grands et toi en 4e et à Roland Garros
un gros tournoi devant devant 20000
personnes 15000 personnes pe non B non
tuuraisi les trois payé les tris premers
tin coup
de
c'est faisable bien sûr que c'est
faisable ça ah ouais bien sûr tu me pas
avecose c'est faisable ça c'est Nouna là
me vont ils vont venir comme ça est-ce
qu'il y a des cadeaux qui en vrai votre
cadeau de rêve ce sera vraiment le
cadeau vous diriez mais wou cadeau de
rêve une opel
corsa personne lu a offert franchement
franchement je vais vous dire je sais
même pas je sais pas vous savez moi je
suis pas un cadeau je suis pas
matérialiste ou je prux faire de l'amour
sen Sen pas les vacances vous aimez
travailler donc c'est même pas des
vacances même pas vacan sin non mais
c'est vraiment c'est c'est c'est de
l'amour une belle montre non de l'amour
je pas vou qu'on vous qu'on vous écrive
qu'on vous aime tous les jours non dei
non pas vous
euh d'autres pas vous euh merci en tout
cas d'être là